what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and welcome to
the pre-game
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos as you
guys know we go live three times a week
here every wednesday thursday and
saturday turn on your notifications so
you can be notified when we go live
second off guys as you know we have a
sponsor today it's cooking with chris
guys if you want to help support the
channel and you want to lose 20 pounds
cooking with chris is the way to go it's
a completely customized meal plan made
with foods you already like third of all
guys as you know if you want to get my
attention during the stream and ask
questions super chat is the best way to
go that helps us support the channel and
helps us what are what are we saving for
again what's it called
a10 mini pro yeah that's what we're
trying to buy i forgot what it's called
um okay guys um so
um to start we have some very special
lovely guests on the channel uh why
don't we start with jess go around say
your name your age where you're from and
your relationship status all right well
my name is jessica jess i'm from uh
southern california and i'm 27 years old
soon to be 28 and like a month and a
half no big deal and i am single
uh sarah garvey
i'm from london
and i'm 41 and i am single
um hello i am marcia i'm 28 i'm from
portugal i live in london and i am
single too
i'm sasha i'm from new mexico i'm 25 and
i'm single
um i'm julia i'm 21 i'm from london and
i'm like single slash complicated
what is what does that mean like i don't
know which one to go for so i just
you know it's like it's like an impetus
like i don't really know what the vibe
is yet oh god yeah
gotcha
okay guys so um
what your relationship is come on no
don't don't be shy give over it okay
okay i'd be lonely
[Laughter]
that's why you're having these podcasts
you know
oh no i'm single i'm 25
and i'm from
chicago jazz
people want to know
um okay so i'm getting ready she went
red bull red for that
okay guys so the topic of today is it's
2022 y'all
do we need feminism in 2022
yes or no go around yeah yes yes i think
so yes definitely yes
no
i'm in between i'm in between you're in
between yeah okay so um
my stance is i i don't see anything
holding women back in 2022 and i don't
know what we need feminism for today
so i'd be curious from the girls that
said yes like what you think we need
feminism for
the pay gap
okay the pay gap yeah um but the pay
gap's not real it still is no it's not
it is
um no every the thing is like when you
take into
account things like like personality
differences the pay gap doesn't exist
like like um for example google did a
study
on like they thought they were paying
women less than men
and they found out they were paying then
eight percent left when they take into
account things like hours worked and
their time time their experience
like there's no there's no pay gap
okay fair enough i don't have statistics
that i will
yeah pass
well
i don't have the statistics to back it
up but um
okay i'll believe it when you say it
yeah okay
it's okay um i i think it's like common
to be honest like a lot of people
like that it's kind of pushed in the
media and stuff but any like economist
that's worth a damn will tell you the
pickup doesn't exist
like women
women aren't in 20 like we make 70 to 80
of consumer buying decisions the entire
media is marketed to women
so i don't know what i'm just curious
like what are we fighting for in 2022 i
mean when it comes to the pay gap it's
like um
it's like this if you advertise a job
on the internet
and say this job is
x and this is a salary
it's not oh this is a salary for women
and this is salary for men right it says
this is the salary so
every person that applies for that job
whether you be male or female is going
to get that salary and one of the major
reasons went for the pay gap is that we
talked about men being more disagreeable
and women be more agreeable so in a job
men are more likely to fight for a pay
rise than a woman is did you know 60
percent of women have never asked for a
pay rise yes 60
so what happens is that men get into
these positions okay it was i don't know
70 000 a year
and it's like they start doing their
work and they're like hang on a minute
i'm doing all of these hours i'm doing
all of this work as a matter of fact i
think i deserve a raise and they go to
the boss and say look
i deserve a raise and so men are
more uh
let's just say forthright with asking
for pay rises so a lot of the time
within the
pay gap is because men have actually
taken the time out to say you know what
i want more women are like yeah you know
what i'm not really gonna go and ask the
boss for more money and stuff and
yeah all right i'm fine with the job
it's a good job men are like no i'm
doing all these hours and generally men
work more hours than women they just
generally do so a lot of the time the
pay gap is because men work more hours
than women do
um
men work
harder jobs than women do
men work in more so in the stem fields
there's
science technology engineering
mathematics not to say women can't go
into those stem fields
we have the same equal opportunities
that you do you can go into science
technology engineering mathematics those
are very high paying jobs but women
choose generally not to go into those
fields they choose to go into other
fields so that's one of the reasons for
the pay gap but there's women on those
fields yeah there are and they get paid
the same as men but in those fields men
choose to yeah get more aggressive and
say listen i deserve more
yeah but probably some women are afraid
to actually ask for more because
probably the boss is a male and he will
say no and most of the times they say no
because you are a woman and they see us
less in a way and actually we are living
in a men's society and let's be honest
still
we need feminism you know but we're not
living in a moment why did you say we
live in demand society sorry like how
are we living in a man's society of 70
to 80 percent because women are afraid
still to ask for a raise
why are you afraid i'm not i'm not i'm
always asking for more every year so
yeah and i i get it but why so why women
why are women afraid then i i don't know
because they probably they've been in
that place and they've been rejected you
know or probably they never like you
said before as well they don't have the
same uh
you know gut feeling as men like going
forward and ask for more but we we know
as women
i i that's my uh that's my how i say
that's how i think and that's how i feel
and that's how i see women back back but
ages ago
but that doesn't mean you're right like
i'm a girl i've always i don't want to
but i'm sorry i'm saying
i'm saying
i'm saying i've always been in male
dominated fields i've never had if
anything it's been easier for me because
like i'm young and like like men
i feel like men are more inclined to
help girls they're attracted to like
just being 100 yeah and it's like i feel
like i've gotten more opportunity being
a girl and you stand out more
like like i was in sales i sold copiers
and like i never had an issue i always
got help from men i never had a problem
asking for more money but then men shame
us
i actually
saw one time a man saying oh why men uh
why women wear makeup while they are
going to their you know workplace
because they are trying to seduce they
are trying you know to get their way
to get what they want probably you know
so you see we are ashamed by men as well
but the the reason is because we use our
looks we are shamed by maybe if we don't
do it
by minute you know it's just like do you
think we have always something to you
know to get judged by men do you and
that's why yeah you know
women are afraid to ask
if you're if but if you're afraid and
that's on you now i'm just saying not me
i'm saying women in general if they're
afraid that's on them and the thing is
we as a man i understand like men
men deal with men a certain way and men
understand like male energy so if a man
goes to a man he understands okay cool
another man's coming to me cool we have
to you know deal with this male energy
if women are afraid to deal with men in
this in this society then i think that's
a that's a woman problem isn't it
because we can have a conversation like
i know every person has male and female
energy as a man and as a woman we both
have those energies and i think of
course a woman has to learn uh how to
deal with that energy and use for her
benefit as as a man as well you know has
to be understanding and more
like to listen more women
than rather like judging you know so
when comes like a woman to actually ask
for like to rate to raise their i'm
sorry my english is a bit i stumble but
anyway
if you if the woman asks more she's
always seen as a gold digger or
um i don't think you are worth as a man
doing that the same job i think he does
better you know
is that is that factual or is that
something that you just feel yeah
because who does that like that's never
like that's never happened to me but
that's you right but it's just one or
two in that you
you know it happens it it can happen in
that way too but it can happen the other
side as well you know this role is quite
big there's a lot of people i don't
believe there is like equality when it
comes to be paid everywhere
well well i don't believe it the
statistics will you can also you're
wrong but you can make me like i said
like donald trump you know there's a lot
of statistics about a lot of and when we
see like real life like real cases
close people then so are you saying
you'd believe what you believe
regardless of any data and statistics
put in front of you
like it does it doesn't matter any any
data it's just like what you
believe
um
i like i like to see real cases like i i
heard a lot about city six and then you
just hear like stories about real people
who come well i'm a real person i'll
tell you but i'm a real person i know
but like so sorry for the statistics
then i'm just saying right people who
are not they exist as well you know so
we cannot generalize all of it
sure sure but i'm saying like it's just
interesting that it doesn't like because
to me if you gave me counter evidence or
counter data that like
showed that the pay gap was real
then sure i would look at it and maybe
change my opinion but i've just i've
researched this a lot because of the
channel
and like i'm telling you there's study
after study after study after study
saying that
the the pay gap
if there is one it's as close as three
percent
and some studies say that women are paid
more than men
so
so it's just like how can i look at all
this evidence and not
have a different opinion you know what i
mean and i understand it's not in front
of you maybe you don't take my word for
it that's fine like you don't you don't
have to believe me but that's what i'm
asking like if you had these studies in
front of you would would that change
your opinion or would you just keep
i'm not doubting what are you saying i'm
just saying i believe there's still
cases out there women are not being paid
like you know as men like the same
that's what i'm saying okay yeah yeah
all
right
no i was gonna say like i understand
where you're coming from because
i
i thought that as well
after seeing a video of
jordan jordan
jordan peterson just wanted to get his
name right he was talking about it and
he's he's not just some joe smo off the
street but he was talking he's a
psychologist very well known professor
and everything it's very good video he
was talking about how
the reason why there is
or
if there is a pay gap is not based on
someone being a man or a woman but
there's
traits that because you were saying
if men and women have those male uh
those masculine and feminine traits and
if a woman would
essentially tap into those
male traits
they would be able to walk up to whoever
it is and be like i deserve to be paid
more because that's a trait that
masculinity has there
it's that like dog in them to be able to
be like no i deserve this but we as
women we
is it empathy or it's agreeable we're
more agreeable we're more agreeable and
it's just who we are so it's a little
bit more difficult for us to be able to
step out not saying that there's not
cases where
women do get paid less than men but
they're also on the flip side where in
certain industry
men do get paid less than women
so like when you take modeling for
example
like women get paid more than men in
that industry yeah supermodels yeah
female supermodels get paid more than
males
okay would you would you like equality
in the supermodel world like the men get
paid as much as the women
yeah it makes sense i mean about
modeling
let's see like for example kendall
jenner she's like one of the most
i think it's the first
billionaire yeah yeah i mean but she
even comparing to other women as well
yeah but i'm saying like if you look at
history when it comes to modeling right
like
supermodels
being women have been paid
far much more than men
like but men aren't saying oh my god we
need equality within the modeling
industry we need to be paid because
there are male models out there and they
do you know they have campaigns and what
but they don't get paid as much as the
women do so they didn't speak out for
that
right exactly so but they could speak
out they they could exactly but they
didn't it's their choice but i'm saying
so do you think that male model should
be paid as much as female models yeah
why not if you guys do the same job why
not what's the difference here
for me it's about equality it's not i
don't see a man or is
a woman more or less i see as we both
are the same level you know we are
humans we are people it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter the gender you know
for me you are a person like me you are
a human you are the same as me we are
the same [ __ ] i'm just saying of course
we are different in gender but when it
comes to rights i think we all deserve
the same so then why so then okay so
let's put that into the real world so
then why would uh why is a woman more
likely to get into a club for free than
the man is
well i didn't do the rule i didn't do
the rules did you know what i'm saying
equality men actually do the rule you
know why because they want more women in
the club than men so they attract men to
pay the bill right so these men are the
hungry ones to get more money so that
makes sense you guys did the math so
that double stance
right so that double standard there that
double standard
was created by men right but but you're
okay with that though oh yeah because we
get in for free right okay so that's
right
that's important
that's it no but that's that's that's
the point that's the point so you're
okay with double standards when it when
it benefits you
you're not okay with double standards
when it doesn't benefit us
if you are getting paid more doesn't it
even if we don't get paid more or the
same as you guys it doesn't like we
don't take your benefits do we no yes
you in some cases yes when you implement
things like quotas i'll give you an
example i worked in the copier industry
they needed women
because selling copiers honestly is a
[ __ ] job i don't know a lot of girls
that want to do it i shouldn't do it
right right
i shouldn't have done it but then they
hired any girl that walked through the
door whether or not it was she was
qualified or not because they needed
women they needed to fill their quotas
and like then you have unqualified women
in jobs they don't deserve
and so and then that hurts men because
you're taking away opportunities from
people that actually are qualified and
deserve them
but the person who to blame here is not
the women who are hired is the person
who hires the people
no the the person to blame is the person
that implemented a quota um because
that's not no no we we women we came
here to get you know our rights uh-huh
but not to say oh i deserve a job even
though i'm not qualified i'm not coming
from there but essentially that's what
in my eyes that's what feminism is it's
just like it doesn't matter
what it is
it should be a right for a woman
so no matter if you're qualified or not
you should be able to get the job
i don't know because that's i don't
agree with that then
i don't i don't i don't see you in that
way yeah yeah yeah
that's earlier you're asking for like
equality when you're like man women
should be paid the same it should be
equal but the question is like equal at
what cost
so so if you if you just pay people the
same if like you say a man and a woman
they're equal but what if one does a
better job than the other and if you
take into account like if you look at
the studies men work longer hours than
women
because you decide to stay long yeah and
so so if you work longer hours you
should get paid more yeah but then it's
good so then the paycheck like so then
right so then
you can't complain about the pay gap for
free no exactly you're right i i'm with
you but i'm saying like so then when men
start making more money we cannot
complain you can't complain we work more
hours let me just clarify when i said
pig up i don't mean people that work
that men that work extra hours i meant
people that do the exact same job that
have the exact same qualifications
getting paid too exactly that's exactly
right if you're only people are not
qualified that's that's your problem no
but then so then like that's that's what
it seems like on the outside but you
can't look at it at face value
because you have to look as to why is
there that gap and so another aspect is
personality differences like what jess
was saying earlier so 60 of women
haven't asked for a raise ever and
they'll quit their job before they ask
for a raise
so is that is that men's fault that we
chose not to ask for a raise
because i i have a friend who
works in
can't exactly remember she works in but
she makes a good amount of money and
when she got a new position
she was like should i ask for a raise
and i was like yes asked for it and when
she asked for a certain amount of money
that was
similar to her counterparts which were
males she got it and i think it's just
something that has been subconsciously
talked to us like don't ask for raise
that's going to be rude if you ask for
more money that they've already given
you when it's not rude if you think you
are worth a certain amount of money and
you are qualified
for a position to go and ask it's
something that we've been
just taught as women it's like don't do
something because
it may ruffle somebody's feather we have
to be peacemakers we can't upset anybody
we have to be calm and situation and i
think that's one reason why we don't do
certain things as women because we don't
want to
upset anybody or
make anybody feel like we're ungrateful
for something that they've already
given us when we shouldn't have to feel
like that if we think that we're worth
something
because in a relationship if you feel
like you're worth more in a relationship
you're going to get out of that
relationship no matter how long it may
take you you're going to be like i'm
worth more in this relationship i'm
going to step out of it but when it
comes down to money it's like
we're
essentially silently ourself because we
don't ask for more plus it's illegal
it's illegal to say i'm gonna pay you
less because you're a woman
it's illegal you can't that's there's no
law that says yeah pay a woman less
so
men and women have to be paid the same
for the same job when they pick more
like dangerous jobs like men are men are
23 times more likely to die in the
workplace than women
yeah so they're going to be paid more if
they pick more dangerous jobs
i think when you put it in that
perspective i guess i like i would agree
with just like i'm in between because
um like back then so what the feminist
movement started around what 1848 when
they first did it i think that's what
yeah 1848 started in new york so like
obviously women were fighting for
something different and um women's
rights are like voting for like just to
vote was like 1920 was in 1920 when the
women first got to vote i think oh gosh
so
back then women were fighting for so
much more and like we're getting
that now so that makes sense when you
guys are explaining it and the
statistics and things like that so just
giving me
a different perspective
on that rather than just
you know just saying we still need
like what i i i would i would ask the
question what rights does a woman have
today
that
men don't have
or what rights do men have today that
women don't
well
in culture in some cultures we don't
still have the same rights for example
in saudi arabia
right feminism probably would work would
would need to go there but we're not in
saudi arabia
sorry
sorry
we're talking about the western world
yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry i should have
clarified i just met in like the uk us
like
in the western world yeah i'm sorry
because i went to saudi arabia so i was
speaking now right
right right
yeah
but the women in saudi arabia will say
we're fine no they're not i've been
there for two months
so i i spoke with them you
you may think that
they're fine i'm not saying that
they're not but
there's they may think in their
situation like oh we're fine here
because they've been in it so long and
you're an outsider looking in and you
have a different view of how a woman's
life should be and you're like you
shouldn't you shouldn't do that that
shouldn't be your life
and
they may think like oh this is what
we've done for so long and i don't know
if you've had people like come to you
and say like you know okay
like for example i was a
monkey there in saudi arabia was a
clothing shop
and she was working at the at the teal
and
she was sharing basically she asked me
oh where are you from you know and i'm
like i'm from portugal but i live in
london and she's like oh my god i'd love
to go to london and but i never traveled
i'm 28. uh i need permission to go like
outside of the country with my like i
need to ask my father to go in order to
visit any other country but he never
like allowed me to go so i'm just like
you know i i don't think i would ever
get out of the country
so she said she has actually to marry
someone
and then
probably probably yes or no
uh the husband
would think would take a second or
someone maybe yeah
you know she cannot even go travel by
herself with which is really really
disgusting
and then you have to cover yourself and
i saw all these men like in high
temperatures i was sweating like a pig
you know i went i had a high job i had
to cover my shoulder i had to cover
everything and
you see you would see men like shorts
and shirts and us all covered you know
and there's women have menopause women
have hormones
okay men too but women have menstruation
women get pregnant women you know
we all go through all pain throughout
life since we are born we as women you
know and
we have to cover ourselves there with 39
degrees
honestly
i feel for the women of course i feel
for every woman because i have to be
that woman but you know okay but we're
talking so we're talking about the uk in
the us
so in in the uk like i'm just curious
because i can't think of a single thing
in the uk and the us we're really
fighting for that we can't do
um
yeah so now yes because we are very like
yeah yeah and the question is like has
it has feminism really helped us are
women happier today
uh
i think so
are women happier today
are you i am
i'm very independent i'm very happy i
get always more i i ask for more i
always get more
so
does independence lead to happiness yes
oh yes when i'm with a man actually
it kind of stops me so so
so if you were 60 it's childless and by
yourself
if you were 65 let's say childless by
yourself no family you'd be like you
think you'd be happy yeah with a dog
she said a dog kevin samuel says buy a
dog and die alone i would have two dogs
so the dog has someone to play with when
i'm not at home so i'm not that selfish
you know but yeah i'll be very happy a
nice house in front of the beach two
dogs there i would have men by like
dessert you know how do you know
28.
see if you're if you think that at 38.
so maybe i'm dead let's see
no i don't wish death on yourself no i'm
not me neither but you never know yeah
but i'm saying like because now i think
like
women that are in their younger years
think yeah
because i'm happy now
right and i
and i'm single now and i'm independent
now
i'm gonna be i'm gonna have this mindset
into my 50s and 60s but when you get to
like your 40s 50s and 60s you tend to
want some kind of companionship you tend
to want somebody who you'd like to like
be with on a day to day or on a
week-to-week basis someone to hold
someone to go to sleep with but you know
it at that point in time a lot of women
tend to think that they're gonna have
the same mindset like i'm 41
right but
yeah i know i look good right yeah black
don't crack
black
melanin who's the secret
but i'm just saying like um a lot of
people think that they have the same i
never had the same mindset that i have
now than when i did when i was 25. you
know i mean 28. you know i mean and at
that age i thought i knew it all i
thought yeah i know exactly what i want
yeah i'm going to be like this rest of
my life i'm telling you
time changes your mind and you may think
that now but as you get to 38 and you
have to be like yeah i'm going to buy a
dog i'm going to be like by myself by
the beach i'm telling you you're going
to want a company
42 that are single childless and make
between 50 and 100 000
are the least happy and the most
medicated
there you go
um
i saw some messages like from elderly
care you know hillary care calorie
people and
most of women they say don't date
you know and they're old
that's that's an example of women they
smile in their face but i've been in a
relationship before for seven years and
i was very happy and i just broke up
because i moved from switzerland to
london you know i know but it is a
relationship i know what it is to be
with someone you don't want that again
oh yes but not now
i just feel
um i had a man it's hot girl summer
season now
and not because
it's hot girl summer season
but it's not because of that it's
because
i feel
a man right now
would uh
delay me in a way because what i want in
life
i just need to be focused i just need to
think about me just me i cannot
share so much time with a person if that
makes sense i hate you yeah so i don't
want to be selfish i don't want to be
narcissist in a way like he's giving me
so much and then i just cannot give the
same so i'm just very aware of that so i
just feel like probably i would have
like
how you say how you call a hook up
there
here and there yeah and there
and that works for you in the machine no
i don't think so that's the thing i
don't think so it doesn't work i want to
try because i never i never tried that's
the thing i'm curious no
because i've been always a kind of girl
like so you relationship you essentially
want to be for the streets
kind of because i don't know the streets
so you want to see what these streets
are about the streets
they put even a caption in the photo
like me is going to fill the streets yo
i like you and i'm like what is that i
want to know that i don't know if you
want everyone is curious right i am
curious she's curious about these
streets okay that's another lie that
like like feminism teaches to women that
sleeping around is going to make you
happy
and it's not you know your your chance
of a happy marriage if you if you're a
virgin when you get married your your
chance of being happily married is 80
right yeah and it drops down to 30 if
you've slept with more than five people
well what come again
it drops down to 30 percent if you've
slept with more than five people
and it just keeps getting lower and
lower
the more guys you sleep with it gets
lower and lower yeah because you know
why you know better what you know what
you want in bed you know sex is it it is
important
right and it's not just sex people think
it's just sex or [ __ ] it's not it's
about intimacy you know and it's about
what you like and what do you for
for
which person for the male or
uh female because i'm just a female i
just talk because as a guy i would tell
you a guy can have sex with a hole in
the wall and be cool
what i'm telling you a guy
a guy can have sex with a woman i i was
exaggerating there but a guy can have
sex with a woman and not need the
intimacy
that's not true
i'm a man i'm telling you a guy can have
sex with a woman and not need the
intimacy ah you don't need it of course
not but i'm just saying it is important
and once you have it believe me it's
much better than sex i don't disagree
with you but i'm saying guys can go
through their life having and that's the
reason why um only fans and porn it in
my opinion why only fans and porn is so
popular because guys can just jerk off
and be cool yeah but women that does
like we watch part two yeah but the
industry is it's a male-led industry
it's like the the most consumers of like
porn and only fans are male 1 they're
not females most women are sexually
active we're men that's not the case one
or three men under 30 are either virgins
or haven't had sex in a year
and that is why only fans and porn is so
um popular because these men these
averages these men are just in their
houses just jacking off and not having
sex yeah ah
you know
they're just jacking off my ideas
they're not having sex sense
because as a as women
scientifically we
release more
i forgot i think ever at the what we
release when we have sex that makes us
want that intimacy with whoever we're
having sex with we there are some women
who can just be like i'm just have sex
with him and not care but there's
something like in the back of your mind
that you still care about that person
because if you saw if you had sex with
that dude one day the next day he goes
and has sex with another female you're
going to feel some type of way because
of what we release
when we have sexual interaction with
them and it's just something that
we cannot
bypass because it's in us so
it's
it's hard to
be able to um
to
sleep around and i mean i'm speaking for
me it's hard to be able to sleep around
with multiple people and not have that
like oh i wonder if he's like thinking
about me or whatever
like because it's just like it's just
what
what like we release when we do interact
with them like that yeah and men can
have sex with like
like i always i've said this so many
times on the show but it's like the day
you realize you have to worry about the
ugly girls too
because like men can have
like men can have sex with literally
anyone anyone anyone
and be okay yeah like so as i said men
can have sex with a woman today and
another woman tomorrow and at three
women today and
be okay and it's not like oh like you
just said it's like he's not thinking oh
i wonder if they're thinking about me
just like no i just yeah
i just done that it's totally different
mindset imagine if a guy gives you the
best sex to your life like mine
she says
been there done that
lucky girl but then then he never talks
to you again like oh he did after seven
years he still texts me
imagine
no but she's saying imagine if a guy did
yeah and i'm saying like he did not
yeah he did sorry
go on pal sorry you get your point now
i'm saying women have a harder time with
that and then it sort of ruins you a
little bit for your husband because now
you compared him like your future
husband to that guy
and that's not really it's not really
fair like guys guys aren't really like
that they they have sex they're good but
like girls will compare
the next guy to the last guy so then
these guys feel like they have to like
be these
corn stars
to like please a girl you know what i
mean and like they feel like they have
these unrealistic standards and then and
then longer way to please a girl than uh
i know she's a man right so it's harder
and yeah yeah it is and most of men they
don't do the work
they just what's that well the work is
is being a hoe basically that's how they
get and that is why and then women don't
then women feminists say oh they can't
be hoes either the guys
but then that's why but that's why paul
that's why the women that get that good
sex keep calling that guy for that good
sex
right and so we we've we they they do
they
nobody generally
she wishes it i call her
the emperor remember when you said the
majority the men who give good sex let's
just say men that give good sex
they have
the women that they've given good sex to
right all of those women want that guy
to give them good sex again so the guys
that are giving good sex to women
are are heavily sought after by these
women
right
and so and so
the other
he's he he understands okay cool like i
have sex blah blah i mean he may be a
hole in the streets or whatever but he
knows that those women will con
consistently be coming back
for him that he knows that that was
because he's given that he's given them
that release that jess was talking about
right and those women want that release
and so when they're comparing the other
guys they're like those guys are just a
bit let me call this guy and he's like
oh okay you're calling now all right
cool so i had a call from susan on the
monday and then i don't know francesco
on a tuesday and he's just like okay
cool here's my options and that's why
they say men are dogs that's why a lot
of the things this whole men are dogs
thing it's because those men are having
sex with these women well and it's
interesting if you ask 80 of women what
they want in a guy they list 20 of men
right so the reason we hate men and they
say things like men are trapped like if
a girl says men are trash it basically
says she's for the streets because it's
the men you're picking and you're
picking the guys that are sleeping with
everybody
yeah women aren't going for average
dudes no
like and this is a degree
all right i love medium ugly men i think
they're great okay i love average men i
think they're better looking than good
looking ones
you know but usually when girls say that
the guys that they they think are medium
ugly are still above average
she's like yeah he's like no i had sex
with a hunchback
with a troll
with a gremlin underneath the bridge
definitely i've never had sex in public
so definitely not under a bridge
it's all right you're young
super chats
okay um so i i see one right here thank
you so much 50 dollar super yes
50 okay okay sentience um
jess what you're talking about is called
pair bonding woman release oxytocin and
dopamine and men release dopamine and
vasopressin oxytocin binds by
binds women rather than men that's why
men can sleep around without breaking
the pair bond
five pounds from d19 he call me pearly
please play devil's advocate once we'd
love to see you argue pro-feminism
separately please give the feminists
more airtime
um
i don't know if i could argue that i'm
sorry
i'll i'll try one of these days
um okay doug mpa jess and sarah just the
just pearly all-stars great show so far
the girl in the red in the middle is for
the streets give her credit for being
honest
i've never been in the streets but thank
you for your review i will show you
where you're going you're now you
weren't that's what you said what you're
trying to be now i'm trying but i'm i'm
not there yet you're not there yet like
next week
there's a lot of men that watch the show
they could
okay
these are
the streets the streets i i don't think
i know the okay the streets means
you're
you're down for anything and everything
your voice is
like
no you said hook up you said you want to
do hookups
you're picking up
like in a club whatever and they were
like oh my god you're hot they're like
give me a number i'm like no
you you know and then comes the next one
if i like
if i don't like i don't even give my
instagram if i like my number i mean if
i like i just give my ice cream then if
i see the weir a weirdo like a stalker
or whatever like creep you know then i
just block
no so i'm not from the streets no you're
definitely not
i thought like it would be like i would
say not be in relationships like just
hook up with someone that you like
sometimes they're sometimes just one
person just one person yeah oh okay so
no i'm not from the streets um okay um
19 star from ammar ali let's change for
let that's changed from 2016. look at
this divorced statistic sense i don't i
don't know what stat you're talking
about sentience another 50 super 50
that camera is going to be coming quick
huh it's going to be here next week the
study that boasted women's only earning
77 cents to the man's one dollar was
funded by a woman's organization that
cherry-picked information to brainwash
the masses in that study it only looked
at all full-time men versus women no
other differences ten dollars from
nel g miller shouldn't talk about the
fact that the soccer team that fought
for equal pay turned down the contract
and that was equal because it was too
much like the men's beforehand and
dropped the benefits
um is there anything else oh good that's
all of them okay sometimes they
disappear so i just want to make sure
so essentially
what you're saying sorry we have one
more super chat from frank alvero uh for
the algo
okay thank you frank thanks frank
um
so that last the second to last super
chat what they're saying is the a
woman's
football team got the same exact
contract as the mail same pay
what they were fighting for
but they opted out of it because it was
too much
like the men's contract okay i i don't
know if that's true or not
if that if that is true it doesn't it
doesn't make
sense because that's something that they
were fighting for and they
wanted and then essentially when they
got it they're like oh it's too much
like the men's but you want
equal equal you want equal opportunity
as the men so it's essentially going to
be like the mess because it's equal
so
that that's something that i don't know
but that's women for you in general
isn't it for me as a man like women
um change their minds women say they
want something and then when they get it
they don't want it anymore and and
that's something that i've seen as a man
throughout my whole entire life like a
woman will tell you that they actually
want something like they want this
nice guy or they want this thing and
then they get it and they're like
it's a bit too
nice guys we wouldn't hate that
balance we don't like too sweet or too
too how you say um player you know we
like player and we like sweet it's like
a mix you know you need to mix otherwise
it's going to be too boring or too
how do you say too traumatized because
players you know they can be a bit
narcissist and they can be a bit
traumatic so it's a bit it's about a mix
about balance if you are too much this
or too much that of course we get it
like ah
okay so can i say as a man right that
that perfect balanced man that you're
looking for doesn't exist i know and so
you
you having that in your head and i think
that's a lot of time why women get
disappointed with men because they've
created this actual man in their head
that actually doesn't exist right and so
you're looking for this man and you
think oh that's the one that's like he
doesn't exist no woman has found the
quote-unquote perfect man yet they're
looking for him though and i think
that's because you guys have been sold a
disney version of what um relationships
are you know like um
there are just good men or and good
women right out there and i think that
this whole oh a man should be this we
want this we want that he's got to be
he's got to have an edge to him but then
he's got to be nice and he's got to be
loyal but then he's got to be a
homemaker but then he can't be tuned out
is that it's like how this list is like
how long
what what is this list how it is the
list
from men about women
our list is very simple
tell us
don't talk too much
okay be cooperative
be a good mother if you if you got if
you've got children
um
and and cooperate like talk too much
what the hell because because we don't
because men like peace so
no women don't like peace
women don't like peace i don't i don't i
i generally don't think women like peace
i think once women get peace they get
bored i think women like excitement
yeah i think they like something a
little bit like a little bit more edgy a
little bit more exciting because if you
give a woman if you give a woman too
much peace she's like oh this is a
little bit boring whereas men will be
happy to be bored for the rest of their
life chill with a woman have this woman
as their woman and be like all right
cool this is my woman for the rest of
her life did you know women only swipe
right between five and fifteen percent
of the time on dating apps where men
swipe right fifty to sixty percent of
the time
why do you think that is
why because women have have to be more
selective we carry a kid for nine months
so it's like in our dna in my opinion
where men were more programmed to like
spread their seed and like women have a
long list of requirements typically as
that prerequisites which sometimes are
probably unreasonable
yeah i think women get disappointed by
their own by their own expectations
expectations yes and i think your ex i
think women's expectations are quite
deluded if i'm totally honest i think
it's like you get i i've known a few
women who have said
oh i wanted this guy and i got with him
but he was too nice i said but you said
you wanted a nice guy
yeah but he was too what the that's too
nice to me what do you mean what do you
mean yeah he was just a bit boring it
was a bit squared he didn't have any
like edge to him it's like
that is why when women go for these
quote-unquote dogs they have that
excitement they have that that that
spice to them they have that edge to
them and then when that man acts the way
he's supposed to act as that type of guy
you get disappointed you're like he's a
dog he's like no well you picked him you
picked him because you saw that edge in
him
i agree with that yeah i think there's
like extreme there's like the two sweet
guy
and there is like the one
the player the excitement but there is
like i i never met a guy that has both
i have a better guy
that has very sweet that was my seven
year uh relationship my ex and then i
met another guy for a year and a half
and he gave me all that excitement and
then trauma
and right still healing
right this is not me normal so why did
you so with this episode if you don't
mind me asking so the seven year guy
what was bad about that like was he what
was bad about that relationship
he's a great guy like when it comes to
heart like he's a great human you know
is he has a good heart i just feel like
he would make me jealous on purpose like
in front of me i don't know why you know
like i was like what the [ __ ] i feel
like it was probably insecure
um and that's your problem and if you
want to talk about it let's talk about
i'm i'm here to listen but i'm not here
to experience your pain or triggering
your frustrations you know if you get
triggered don't put it on me
um
so yeah he was making me jealous and
then on my birthday for example i
actually got traumatized because
uh honestly
so he was next to me and a girl was next
to him
and
he was talking to her i don't mind talk
who the [ __ ] you want
but then he was pretty sounding like you
minded
i'm not gonna lie it sounded like you
did mine because that's what i'm telling
you right now is because he was talking
to her and he was putting his hand on
her leg and it was like glue on his hand
he didn't just touch and you know took
off it just let his hand there
like had glue for five minutes and then
i pinched myself and on my birthday i
just felt like
what the [ __ ]
you know
sorry
oh sorry
wow
i didn't mean to like make you tell that
story and like get upset
they are
anyway
so
yeah it's my birthday you know it's your
day it's a day that you cannot forget
you know because you're gonna always
remember
and
[Music]
it's hard when
it's
situations like that that
make you
think about
just other situations because seven
years is a long time
and
if i were you i'd be like i'm for the
streets too forget him i'm out here
i'm gonna go around and find something
better so
it's
it's hard to want to
find the person that you you want and
you have these things and you
essentially get that person
but they
is as what you want but and at the end
it's like not what you want you're like
i never i never thought that that person
would have done that but it's like we
we cast our vision on what we
um
what we what we want but we don't see
past it's like our hand is like our hand
is our vision but we can't see past our
hand because our hands in the way and
what what they really are is behind our
hand but we don't move it because like
this is what i want this is what i see
and i want this but what they really are
is behind it and i feel like we as women
have
have standards which we should for
ourselves
but it's so
astronomical that we're not able to
really see who a person is so stuff like
that happens because we have these
standards and this image of who we want
in our lives that we can't see the
reference or we see them but we don't we
don't acknowledge them or we don't um
say anything about we brush it off like
oh
it was just plain they were just funny
but in the end it's like man
what is it that us as women really want
do we all want men that are over six
foot
or do we really want someone that is no
matter how boring they are that is going
to
care for us in those
days where we should if we should be
celebrated and that aren't going to step
out or not going to do things that they
know are going to hurt us
yeah definitely
but that was not my relationship with
seven years that i had with my ex that
was the relationship there recently for
a year okay okay yeah because that was
the extreme the player that i was
talking and the other one that was so
sweet so loyal so good because there are
good really good ones out there
that was with the seven years yeah i
just broke up with him because i moved
to london and i was in switzerland with
him yeah
uh but yeah definitely i agree with that
why didn't you marry him then you would
here for seven years because i don't
want to marry you no i don't want to
marry now i i want to have a family i
want to marry but i want to take care of
my mom first my mom is my baby
so i want to focus on my career
and i want to provide for me and for my
mom
and then
you know get married and get a family
okay that's my plan
yeah
what if
and
i i hope like you don't feel like the
spotlight's on you this is like just a
general question if anybody was in that
situation that had to take care of a
parent what if there was someone that
came into your life that was like i will
stand behind you no matter what it is
that you have to do and i will be there
for you to help you take care of your
mother whatever it is no matter if i'm
here if i'm away would you reconsider
like if your
boyfriend for seven years was like i'll
move to london with you i will help you
take care of your mother like i'm here
for the long run would you have
stayed with him
yes but he didn't want to he didn't want
to move to london because he came here
though to experience the life and he
didn't like you think he thought he was
too
chaos chaotic
thank you
yeah it is understandable because in
switzerland it's very peaceful it's very
organized israel is one of the most
amazing countries to live when it comes
to family you know low crime as well i
think yeah yeah it's very safe it's
when it comes to lifestyle it's very
luxury even like for example for the
cleaner she gets like 5 000 a month you
know and you can save travel
so it is pretty clean it's pretty you
know
respectful towards people towards nature
towards animals you can get even your
dog to the restaurant to the supermarket
everything you know so it's pretty good
and they have the best schools and all
that and he kind of like want that for
his future and for his family and i
respect that so i had to you know get
what i want and he i respect like i wish
him the best honestly
so to get what he wants
you know so yeah i just feel like when
he comes
to get married and all that if even if i
have a guy in the future
telling me that he would be able to
help me
i think i would be scared
because i'm very used to being dependent
since i was younger since i was like a
child since i was like 10.
i was i was i had to take care of me and
my mom so i just feel if i have someone
now to take care
of me and my mom
i feel
it's abusive like i'm taking an
advantage i don't know i just feel like
i don't know
um do you ever like
like do you ever worry about running out
of time to get married like it might be
harder if you wait longer
i thought about that too i'm like
especially if you want to have like a
family and stuff
yeah but i'm very spiritual i i believe
in a lot a lot about the law of
attraction and about
you attract the people that you need to
attract at certain moment to
learn certain types of lessons and i
think the right if you are not in a fear
place
about that if you let go
yeah i think you're going to meet the
right person at the right time and
things will suddenly happen because
there's amazing stories out there it's
not from disney no but there's like uh
stories up i mean real stories out there
that i seen couples getting married and
getting a family later on you know even
early
so
there's a bit of
everything i feel i think we just are
putting people in boxes and realities
they are limited
like probably uk realities
you know i'm not for the uk reality um
but you you realize like 50 of women
over 30 are single and childless
so there's a lot more um cases where it
didn't work out than it did
so this manifestation thing
can i just like bring it back like this
whole manifestation law of attraction
thing
sounds great um on paper but
statistically when you look at it like
pearl said like over 30 and you're less
likely to like get married and stuff
like that and the thing is um as a man
it's very interesting that um
i think like echo chambers are a thing
like so
i think when
one of the reasons why
men get um like attacked
when
they speak the truth about statistics is
because women live in echo chambers
amongst women so women can sit amongst
other women and say yeah manifest him
girl you know you the law of attraction
is great like you don't worry he's
coming you're
you're your guy's coming it's like and
men are like
what the hell are they talking about
like
get on like because as men
when we want to do something we start
doing it we start like making the plans
to do something right and it's like if
you don't make plans to do something
and thinking you can like kind of wish
it into existence really and truly nine
times out of ten nothing actually gets
done
so this whole thing of
uh oh yeah i'll wish him into existence
and the law of attraction in the right
time blah blah blah
it's hard for men to hear that because
that table right there wasn't wished
into existence do you know what i mean
it was a man said i need to make a table
and i'm going to make a table i'm not
going to i'm not going to think about it
and think yeah it's going to say
i want to wish to be a billionaire into
existence right it's just like you have
to put plans into consideration if you
manifest it it could happen yeah but it
more than likely won't and like like i
come from a very my dad's very very
successful but he got there by working
80 hours a week my whole life i barely
saw him it wasn't by manifesting it
okay i mean have you read the secret
the book i've read it i've read it i've
actually read the secret it's a it's a
great book it's a great book and i think
it i thought that guy was a con artist
no i think i think no i swear to god it
came out he was a connor i think
essentially what the secret teaches is
good
i think essentially what because things
have to start in your mind before they
become
um into before they make it into
fruition and i get that that table
started in somebody's mind first before
it became a table it didn't just become
a table somebody thought about making it
a table and they said okay cool this is
what's gonna happen but they had to work
to actually get it done manifest
something and it helps you get there it
also takes working but obviously if you
start manifesting and telling yourself
every single day this will happen i can
make this happen it helps you actually
physically do it but i can help you but
but it doesn't come with no okay of
course you know you can't just say oh
i'm going to be a billionaire tomorrow
we'll see when a lot of people a lot of
people think that when it comes to
manifestations yeah but obviously that's
not what what it is yeah yeah yeah um
it's just that's what i when i first
heard about manifestation and all this
universe i was like so essentially
people are just writing down things and
saying this is gonna happen and just
sitting back and relaxing i was like you
still have to put in some work with it
um but i do have a question for the
women
you had um you had said something about
um
being independent and if someone did
come to you
and
approach you for a relationship you'd be
scared when it comes to feminism do you
think that
it has taught women to be more
independent so when that
suitor that you've had in your mind for
so long does approach you you are so in
this independent mindset that
it it scares you because it has feminism
has taught you be independent be on your
own do you don't let a man do anything
for you think that's a hindrance to
women or it helps women in the end this
is a question for
everybody
it goes both ways i guess
yeah i think it's a bit in a limbo you
know when it comes to that um it's good
to be independent i think it's good to
not rely on a man because if you're
married and you don't have kids and
again yesterday we were talking about
this like if the relationship goes wrong
and both they get a divorce you know and
then you don't work you don't have an
income
and then you're just like what you know
what the hell my what am i gonna do you
know uh so yeah it's good to be
independent it's good to make your own
money but at the same time
i mean if a man wants to provide and the
woman is fine to be at home you know
it's okay i don't judge but at the same
time society does everything i feel like
there's so many snowflakes out there
which is if you do if you if you choose
this they have something to say if you
choose that they have something to say
like who is like if you are with a rich
man you are a gold digger if you don't
work and he's rich you are a gold digger
well do you think that social if the if
the woman is rich and the man uh is not
you know like probably the woman is
older and he's younger oh you are a pimp
you know
there's always something to say there's
always something to judge these people i
feel like if we're less judgmental
judgmental and more understanding and
actually judge ourselves first and see
in the mirror and then
judge you know
i think it's just too many snowflakes in
this world i just feel like
do you think sometimes that's like
social media though like you wouldn't
know 99 of people's opinions if it
wasn't for social media that's true yeah
you delete all social media tomorrow no
one will say anything to you not to your
face
i don't care for example i saw the
our live yesterday i saw on youtube i
was reading the comments they were a few
they were mean and i was like
i was actually you know eating and i was
like oh so good you know i don't give a
[ __ ] they even criticize credits i how
do you say this word criticized
criticized thank you
beyonce come on look at her huh can you
do better than her you know what i mean
so who the [ __ ] who are you but i think
the question is like do you mean all day
long but but i think you made me money
every word that he was saying
but i think the question is like do we
want to live our lives in a state of
fear like do we want to live like a fear
of what people are going to say or fear
fear of a man leaving or fear like we
it's kind of no because what i've found
is girls that live their lives like that
they end up alone because they're too
afraid to let someone in
yeah and then and that's worse because
the the biggest increase in the homeless
population is older women you need two
incomes to retire for most women if
you're not making six figures or close
to it you need a second income otherwise
you'll be on the streets right
because um it takes one cancer diagnosis
to put us on the streets but feminism
keeps telling us in the u.s yeah what in
the us oh yeah maybe not right in the uk
we got the national health service to
help us with that until until it runs
out
i mean national health service has been
going for a while in the uk you know i
mean like you you in the u.s
yeah like in the us you guys have got
like private insurance and stuff like
that so
yeah right but the point is you still
you still need two incomes to retire
though
and
like it's feminism tells you you don't
you don't need a man but we do
or a girl i don't discriminate you
human we need love we are you know into
that like we are yeah i think i think
human beings like human beings need
companionship yeah do you know what i
mean like um we currently live in a time
where you know whether you've been on
social media or not like it seems to be
like this gender war going on do you
know what i mean and it's like men hate
women women hate men blah blah blah and
it's like essentially that is only going
to lead to more loneliness essentially
do you know what i mean and it's just
like if you don't if you're not able to
find some kind of middle ground as men
and women then you're just all going to
be lonely you get to be all going to be
lonely and hateful like come on guys
like we need to kind of find some kind
of middle ground you know what i mean
and i i just think that um
yeah i think i think men are actually in
this society they're quite upset about
feminism because feminism has taken on a
very aggressive stance he's taken on a
very aggressive like
sorry go on paul did you know that even
first wave feminism was aggressive like
even the earliest
like forms of feminism was aggressive
but then it needed to be what i think
first wave feminism maybe it needed to
be aggressive i don't know there was
like bomb threats well not not that
aggressive
not that aggressive there was like um i
i can't remember off the top of my head
but rolo tomasi talks a lot about it
like even first wave feminism always was
a aggressive and had a disdain towards
men
like i think feminism has always been a
gender war
i i i i wouldn't disagree with you
because even even if we talk about the
right to vote like they act like it was
men against women but it wasn't women if
you voted you were part of the draft
who's trying to be part of the draft not
me
if i had to give up today that's
equality you gotta go out there and grab
a gun and start shooting what are you
talking about nope i don't want any
quality in that
if if voting today had to come with the
draft i'm i'm a scaredy cat i don't do
that but the thing is that's very
interesting because feminism uh is
essentially women say and i don't
generally believe them they say it's
about equality but then about equality
in what form like i said if there was a
war to break out tomorrow
are you saying that the army should be
half women and half men most women do
not want to
go out and fight in a war right men
understand that there may be their duty
to protect their country their children
their wives the women of the country and
that is one of the things that
a lot of women don't take into
consideration
men do
some of the stuff that women just don't
want to do
goes both ways
i'm saying the thing is we're talking
about how it what it takes to build an
actual society and keep it running men
understand there is a duty to keep the
society running this house was probably
built by men this this camera
scaffolding the irrigation systems
plumbing all of this stuff men
understand that this has to make society
run but you just want my house to a home
it's a woman right but we're not talking
about that we're not talking about the
thing is to make a home just to make a
home you need a house yeah to make it
home so you're talking about the after
the you're talking about aftercare
nobody
okay so if okay so okay so
at least 90 to 95 percent of bricklayers
are men
yeah the people that build houses
are men now women have the opportunity
to be bricklayer bricklayers but they're
not choosing to be bricklayers why
it's nature as men
exactly so
exactly so that's what i'm saying so no
i'm not blaming anyone i'm saying if you
understand that men have to take the
dirty grueling dusty jobs right to get
the society done then really and truly
you ain't got nothing to complain about
because without the dirty grueling dusty
jobs that we do you wouldn't even have a
house to live in
anyone's asking the men to take those
jobs no we do no it's not you asking us
we understand we it has to be done
that's on the menu all right so then you
want to live in the wilderness sure yeah
i don't want to pay rent
oh
my god all right so go live in the
wilderness then
well no don't live in a goal
these days
no you're choosing not to it's it's very
possible not really yes it is if you get
it if you get a van if you get a van
i've seen a lot of people i don't have a
driving license okay
you can get a tent though
go camping never come but you're driving
in shocks is most likely going to be a
man
because you understand that society is
going to need to drive
that's not like men have this inbuilt
thing of
um whether it be conscious or
subconscious that the society that they
live in needs to be pushed forward okay
they can't just
sit around looking at dresses right i'm
not being disrespectful but they can't
sit around on bloody asos or pretty
little things looking at dresses and
looking at i'm just saying that we we're
not like oh yeah whimsical stuff yeah
let's manifest everything men are like
listen [ __ ] has to get done around here
for society to move and the thing is a
lot of the time men feel
a lot of this is what men are feeling
now and i think it's a lot of the time
the reason for like the the ism and
schism between men and women men are
like but hang on we built this [ __ ]
like we like we built this like how are
you going to hate us without
the internet which was a male
built thing you wouldn't have been able
to talk on the internet about men and
talk [ __ ] well we don't hate you because
you are doing those jobs who's saying
that so
i'm not talking about you i'm saying but
it's still talking about feminism
and it's even like even in this
conversation like we always say oh well
that's not the men's like that's that's
the men's fault if they that happens
like it's like that disdain is it's not
it's not i love men
i know what we should like i'm not
saying that you don't i'm saying that
when it comes to feminism
feminism in these days and time seems
like it's like a um
like it's against me like men of this
the patriarchy oh my god misogyny but
it's like listen without patriarchy and
misogyny you wouldn't even have a house
no to me feminism is like if a man goes
and has sex with 10 women you know he's
cool but if a woman does that she's a
[ __ ] that's what feminism is to me it
should you know they should both be cool
they should both be [ __ ] the reason
why
okay but then preach but okay but if the
biology is a dead but the biology
doesn't support you
right so that's what i'm saying like if
we're about feminism do you think it's
fair that we should give the facts to
younger women and say hey if you sleep
with more men your chance of a happy
marriage goes down drastically yeah
women should have all the statistics i
don't know that was a statistic like i
didn't know that was a fact yeah and and
this is what i'm saying like
like the men and women are different and
men and men don't have that same thing
like men if they sleep with more women
they're happier
like okay so go take australia for
example right um
in australia they made um prostitution
legal
right they made prostitutes and legal in
australia
and in australia they made they but what
but what they done
but what it done with prostitution is
that it brought it into
houses it wasn't on the streets right so
you have what you would call them [ __ ]
houses or whatever right but like
there's like 24-hour like uh-huh you
know prostitution houses right and you
know what happened when they made
prostitution legal in australia
the divorce rate in australia went down
by eight percent
really yeah
it was kind of like a show went
men were happier going to whorehouses it
seemed like right and being able to do
that
then when they weren't when prostitution
was illegal so it's kind of like a peep
show house
and how would i'm just curious how would
feminism fight for like the equality
when it comes to sleeping with people
because you can't
change society like you can't
you can't look at everyone in this room
and say look at everyone the same like
they're not going to
i don't know what you mean um okay so
there are biological reasons the way we
feel the way we feel so in general women
date men taller than us
and the reason for that is because
historically like we used to have to
find a guy to protect us so if he was
taller than us he could protect you
better so men it's the same thing with
body count
historically they couldn't have a girl
that slept with a lot of people because
they had to ensure paternity they had to
make sure that the kids
was there and they weren't raising
someone else's kid
so they can't help that they feel that
way about girls sleeping around it's
just part of their hard-wiring just like
we can't help that we feel that way
about wanting tall men
and like girls will say like short men
ain't [ __ ] short like i wouldn't ever
and look at i'm sorry i'm one of them
sorry short king
i won't say they're ain't [ __ ] but like
i just like i'm more attracted to guys
taller than me
and like men don't complain about that
like double standards in that way
i mean i just don't think like feminism
is a so so it's your sociological thing
but you're talking about a biological
thing so you can't really compare the
two
so i don't understand so you're saying
it's a social media honestly me neither
i'm really confused
look
i'm just saying like
the reason why men find women that sleep
around um
i guess negative
is because
like he's like pearl said we need to we
need to secure the fact that our seed
our legacy so what you're basically
saying is that men can't help being like
that because it's a biological thing
yeah it's a biological thing okay well
that's just changed it then like biology
can be changed within a lot of time with
time with time yeah
actually i heard women about women than
men no how come you come like a
biological thing that men have more
because women are attracted to men that
have more sexual partners but women get
hornier actually a woman wants actually
sex way more than a man yeah but okay no
okay how come hang on
biological
that way that could that could be true
it is true but
no no i'll say that could be true but
when a man is a virgin he doesn't know
what he's doing in the bedroom is that
attractive
it's cute
[Music]
she is the exception i said
i said
i said is it attractive is it is it
attractive it's not a bad thing everyone
so a man so okay so a man like i said
earlier on the conversation a man that
knows what he's doing in the bedroom
yeah that knows what he's doing is more
attractive to a woman a man that knows
what he's doing in the bedroom is
experienced okay in sex he's experienced
right he knows what he's doing a man
a man doesn't mind teaching
a woman what to do in the bedroom so if
she's less experienced than him right he
doesn't mind teaching her and kind of
like what people call turning someone
out right a man doesn't really mind
turning a woman out in a bedroom right
but a woman doesn't want to be the one
to tell a man how to please her where
the clitoris is what to do with her body
she's like oh my god this guy doesn't
know what the hell he's doing
right so you want a man who's sexually
experienced
but you have to tell every man where the
[ __ ] is
well i don't know what man you've been
talking to
everything sarah said i know
every time she don't speak for every
single one how are you you're 20.
how does a man feel about that then
since like if a woman you're saying like
if a woman
doesn't
like a man who's not experienced what if
the roles were reversed so how would men
think about a woman
yeah so okay so i'm i'm okay this is
very interesting inside the man of a man
so a man who finds a woman that's got a
lot of experience understands that she's
been quote unquote for the streets
right
and he will have sex with her
but he won't make her his wife
thoughts
he won't he won't he would definitely
have sex with her and he'll enjoy that
sex but he's not thinking this is gonna
be my wife she's been with like a
hundred men or whatever he's been
thinking
whatever whatever number you put in your
head i'm just saying he's a legendary
girl
that's not true i know there are some
there are some women
think like that but i think that's real
really wrong because probably
are you telling me that a man as a man
woman who is very experienced in sex
it's because probably she's been in a
long relationship and she knows a lot
because she's been you know doing for a
long time period not just with one
person and then on another person you
know what i mean it's just like uh i
feel like that's very judgmental
you can feel the way you want to feel
but i'm just saying as men like that
you're very experienced you've been with
a lot of hoes too you are a hoe as well
no no but women women are okay women
want a man with sexual experience they
want a man with sexual experience so you
as a man what do you want from a woman
not experienced so you can feel the men
we understand this is teaching her
yeah
yeah yeah exactly
you
and my thoughts so i'm saying you guys
want a girl that has no much experience
so you guys feel like ah macho man you
know ah i'm the teacher i teach you
you're feeling part of like ego right
you guys have a big ego yep
okay good good okay good for you so
anyway i would say you see i lost a lot
let's train the food because you're
talking about down there that's why no
because you imagine very much
your mind went elsewhere
focus
you confirmed
so in order a man to be uh able to be
experienced you need to try
different girls right right right but
those girls have been experienced by you
by other men too right but how come you
think you're gonna find a woman then
that is not an experience
no like i said um and i said this on the
show before there is a there's a fine
line and i think you know i think some
men may be a little bit delusional here
but there's a fine line and we want a
woman we we know that women of this this
generation aren't virgins we know that
we know you've had a few sexual partners
maybe a few relationships etc etc but we
don't want to know that you're a
quote-unquote it's probably going to
upset people we don't want to let you we
don't want to know that you're a whole
we don't want to know that you're a
whole okay what we want is okay cool we
know we're not the first guy that you've
been with
we know that but we don't want an actual
hole that's been with like a hundred men
that's not what we want but if you but
if you act that way we're like okay cool
this is cool sex great sex but i ain't
gonna wipe this girl because she's been
like i could be walking down the street
and the next guy walks past me and he's
like
um
that's your girl
that's your girl yeah oh we me and my
friend's done
yeah okay
okay but that's again judgmental because
for example i've been in a relationship
for seven years and then i met this guy
for a year and a half and he wanted a
and he's arab and he wanted to marry me
you know and i'm more experienced than
him no but i'm saying you were in a
relationship that's different you were
in a relationship with one man for seven
years that's different we're talking
about a woman who's been with that
but how do you know she's been like that
you don't want to know but that is why
that is why people ask about people's
body count
because they want to know uh-huh i don't
know how many people you've been with
i mean what the same for
no
i can't speak for every female though so
for me like if i heard his body count
was like 50 or 100 i'd be like oh my god
have you been tested
right yeah yeah yeah no no that's not
for me that's not attractive to me
i don't want i don't want to hear like
like like i said they don't want to hear
about a cat i don't want to hear that i
don't want to hear that you've slept
with the 50 to 100 people
but you do want him to be sexy
experience though
i would say personally yeah
yeah but i just don't want you like
so i guess to an extent so drake asks to
take you on a date yeah drake asks to
take you on a date
you're not going
i heard about him he's fine but you know
okay a date's fine a date's fine but if
you get a free meal
ritz carlton
he's trying
he's trying to date you
or a guy like that it might not be drake
but your celebrity crush okay okay
that's clearly been with a million okay
so if he told me
this is me personally if he told me he
was like with 50 or 100 men it's
probably more of those guys
i don't i couldn't do it you couldn't i
couldn't do it i don't care how famous
they are i just personally couldn't do
it
do you think you're more of the
exception though rather than the rule
because like it's just historically the
reason women tend to like
men that other women want is because
historically like if you saw that a guy
could was sleeping with a lot of girls
that means they selected him indicating
that he could take care of you because
he could take care of them
oh
i don't know
so i think so i think when we get to the
extreme like sure 50 100 maybe that's
much but it's like i think you'd
probably rather have a guy that slept
with 20 girls than zero
yeah what is it for you yeah because
then you got then you gotta teach him
everything
when you put it chilly
but for some people for some people
that's okay if they've got a teeth
she likes to teach you teach me julia's
young yeah julia's young that's fine
like you can't women don't haven't slept
with many people myself so like to me
it's like i've been there
right
but
so you slept with a few people fine so
you get this virgin dude
yeah
and he's at home what am i supposed to
do
i would say i would say someone who's a
virgin nowadays
they may not physically
know what to do they may not have been
with somebody no but they've seen it so
i feel like
there shouldn't be
that shouldn't
but
everyone has seen it to an extent they
should know know what to do and
yeah i just cause what they could
they've been watching corn yeah
and so
i feel like there's
when it comes to virgins they may be
physically aversion but mentally
okay that's interesting
never thought about that realistic
expectations
unrealistic expectations if they watch
porn yeah
unrealistic unrealistic there are real
people who can do that too
you know what you watch oh i had it
it's good yeah
okay hi
hi david
she misses you
davis
davis he texts me oh yeah after six
years he does still like text and he's a
nominee he's very good he's a bodyguard
he's a private bodyguard he's really
really good looking okay but yeah
david the bodyguard
super chad
sorry sorry
just gonna read out some stupid chats we
have ryan
um if anything happens to s-a-r-a
garyvee garvey sarah garvey oh garvey
sorry um i will be depressed protect
this man
listen follow my youtube right now
follow my youtube whoever that is
okay um let me just get the next one
um i think it's
okay
249 from maverick s when feminists say
men are trash down the patriarch that is
judgmental
um i think there's one
from let me see okay guys you already
know hundred dollar super chat
hundred dollars was that last one two
hundred and forty nine dollars no it's
249 like of some currency oh okay
like
it could be something that's more
expensive than a dollar you never know
if it's in pounds is more expensive than
no okay i don't know
i don't know why pay is money i
appreciate it
i like saw how much it was worth and it
was like five dollars i'm like no
anyways um sentience final thought as i
leave why would any man who you deem
worthy um
opt for you as you age accumulate
emotional and physical trauma and rooted
in your ways when you get a younger
version of you age equals thirty ninety
percent ninety percent of your eggs are
gone by thirty thirty five is geriatric
pregnancy forty plus is genetic
abnormalities
jesus what abnormalities uh
[Music]
90 of your eggs are gone by 30. 90 19 90
yeah
and then we talk about your price yeah
my eggs now no but you know
do you have 40.
if you want to do geriac if you want to
like freeze your eggs do you have forty
thousand dollars when the time comes to
only like possibly have a shot at a kid
children
so don't wait wait wait i'm sorry so
you you mean to freeze them i need to
pay
40 000. yeah i don't know how much it is
in these 40 000. and that's it and it's
my ex
well no if you want it's not to freeze
them it's to if you like later you want
to like actually do the treatment that's
very expensive
and that's what they take though right
yeah
so it's like that's like but this is
what i'm saying when feminism like lies
to us because they say you don't need a
man push off marriage push off kids push
like focus on your career but you only
have so much time
like if you were if you were barren
tomorrow like i think most women would
be devastated even the ones that say
they don't want kids i will adopt them
you know if yeah which is fine if you're
okay with that but that's again
expensive like that's that's around i
think that's at least 10k
okay
i said out loud
it's okay and there's a lot of there's a
lot of problems that come with adoption
like my my parents adopted three
teenagers that like needed like i have
nine siblings total but there's a lot of
like behavioral issues that come with
adoption especially if you
like even if you get them pretty young
the baby like their their thoughts form
at a very young age there's a lot of
issues that come with it
like um i forgot i forgot they say like
i don't know what percentage of brain
development is before the age of two but
it's it's the majority so a lot of times
like
there's issues that come with it yeah
lots of trauma from their previous yeah
the previous household which is fine
like my parents adopted i think it's a
great thing but mm-hmm
i'm not i don't
experience any
like did you see any situation happening
with those people yeah
others i mean i wouldn't talk about it
on camera but there were problems yeah
and like um i mean some some of them
worked out fine but
that we also gave up a kid for adoption
because my mom got pregnant when she was
17 and they gave up that kid and he
turned out great like great family but
it just it's like luck of the draw and
i'd say you're it's kind of like 50 50
shot to be honest
um
so it's like they don't they don't talk
about this though because you're just
told you have all the time in the world
we don't
our window is small now ninety you sure
it's easter it's ninety percent ninety
percent eggs at thirty yeah sure and
it's it's it's um i don't know
i've heard that it's like you need to
have a kid in your like it's a lot
harder if you haven't didn't have a kid
in your twenties like if you you're
secondary
forget it i'm i'm i'm okay with not
having children yeah but then but then
and then it goes back to if you don't do
that and you choose to not have kids you
need two incomes
if you want to retire
you know i'm just i'm gonna go back to
california they paying homeless people
six hundred dollars to be homeless and
i'ma just be homeless and live my life
you know
the average cost of envy true
oh i think i was wrong about that um
our in vitro say treatment costed our
life savings which is about forty
thousand dollars the average cost of in
vitro is often quoted at 12 000. i don't
know i don't know the exact number but i
know it's most people don't have 10k
sitting in their bank account
yeah
i feel like sometimes it sounds like
maybe not necessarily but like a
lose-lose for women sometimes because
you know if we're not ready right now in
our 20s to have kids or get married but
the statistics like the percentage goes
down because we choose to wait or
whatever the situation is so it feels
like sometimes it can be
a loser's because i'm not ready to get
married right now i don't want to have
kids right now so
obviously the window closes when we get
in our 30s by night it's like 90
so that's why feminism made women
unhappy
yeah
well i need to find that it told you
that you were going to be more happy but
essentially it seems like women are more
unhappy
when they as they get older and it's
like it's cool now like i'm not saying
it's not cool now and people are more
happy now but i'm saying as you get
older it's like
damn like what she should have cut away
like
i could have done that i should have
done this one in three
what kind of like motive is
to explain to me why like one of the
reasons why you're saying that
um because the statistics show that
women above 30
or who are who are childless
um manless
are more unhappy they're the most like
people said they're the most medicated
one in one in three one in four women
are over that are
one in three women over the age of i
think either 30 or 35 are on
antidepressants
like women are unhappy when as they get
older
i don't know actually as a matter of
fact i don't know the statistic when it
comes to men but what i what i will say
is and like i said before
companionship is a thing like it's not
something that should be looked at as oh
i don't want a partner i don't want not
like feminism's like you don't need no
man girl
like but the thing is that that is what
it's become it's become that perception
of feminism though what do you mean so
like
before feminism women were forced to get
married to men they didn't like to have
kids they didn't want
they couldn't have careers they had to
sit at home with kids you know
so a woman my age would most likely buy
now 21 be married have like two kids
that she doesn't probably want if it was
me i don't want kids right now i'm
living my best life i'm living on my own
you know i'm working i'm dating i'm
my best friend every weekend you know
doing whatever we want to do i don't
want kids right now like i would i would
most likely pull a header gobbler and
off myself if i was in her situation for
reference it's just like a political
play
um in which a woman got pregnant and
killed herself because she didn't want
to be pregnant but she had to be
pregnant and married because it was the
social norms at the time so then how
long does this
live in my best lifetime last and so i
meet the person i want to spend the rest
of my life with people
going back to what if you have been in
that state of i'm living my best life i
love being alone i i don't i don't know
what it is to be with somebody else and
you do meet that person and because
you've had this thought of i'm living my
best life and this this is my best life
and i'm living it and i don't want
anybody else to come in but you have
this person that you've you dreamt of
but you're scared that they're going to
mess up your best life
so is this like hypothetical yeah yeah
yeah
how do you know you're living your best
life if you're living it alone um so
so i'm single now and i'm the happiest
i've ever been but i'm i'm getting to
know someone at the moment like you know
and i'm not stopping opportunities from
coming i'm not not seeing people like
i'm
i'm not closing that window off but i
would never ever be with someone now if
they didn't add to my life
someone has to i can give myself
anything i want i'm so happy right now
so if i let someone in it's to
lift me up and to add value to my life
so what about you adding value to their
life of course yeah and that as well
right okay so you added you add value to
each other's lives and then you move
forward as a together right okay
um i mean you're 21 so i would say
you've got time yeah yeah i would say
baby girl you know but when you when
when you listen to women in their 30s or
when you listen to when you listen to
kind of women in their 30s who have
quote unquote lived their best life hot
girl summer yeah i'm gonna do what i
want to do independent so like
those are the types of women sorry just
sorry to cut your bell those are the
types of women that call into kevin
samuel's show
angry
and pissed off
like i'm 30 i've got two baby dads and
now i want mr prince charming and he's
like
calm down
like you
you you wasted quote unquote
your 20s
living your quote-unquote best life and
now like i said your mind state changes
okay when you start to get older and now
your mind stay changing and realize hang
on a minute maybe i need a partner maybe
i need but by that time you've already
made all of the quote unquote mistakes
that you've made and you're living with
your mistakes and now you're asking some
next
perfect man to come and rectify the
mistakes that you've already made it's
unrealistic
i'm just saying and i don't want it to
happen for you i really don't i want you
to live your best life find your partner
go off it and into the sunset i want a
boyfriend i think they're great yeah but
i'm saying a lot of the time like people
like just to talk about kevin samus for
a second people like hawking about kevin
samus and how he's this and how he's
that and i'm like kevin samuels as much
as as harsh as his delivery can be and
you know i mean like i see how harsh his
livery can be
he's telling women
listen no one
in this days and times sorry you had the
the opportunity to live your
quote-unquote best life and these is
this is what you chose you chose to get
with
ray ray and pookie whoever they are
right and they they impregnated you
right and now you got two kids for two
baby baby fathers and now in your 30s
you're now asking for a different result
you chose your result
you may be i'm not saying you can't
rectify but nine times out of ten
it's not going to happen yeah but that's
a good observation
because that makes me think i thought
about it before but it makes me think
like in the future like
what kind of partner i should choose
guilty definitely because i think it's
fun it's like all fun and games you know
you go to your best life you party
you just like you know have fun
and you don't have any commitments
yeah but then
you're like
yeah for how long for how long how long
does it look and the thing is a lot of
women
have that oh i'm gonna party and live my
best life into their 30s maybe sometimes
and they're like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] what am i
gonna do now it's too late you lived
your quote-unquote best life for too
long whatever that best life was and now
you want something a little bit more
stable and it's like well
oh okay
i've said this sorry i'm going a little
bit of a tangent but
um
men that are in their 30s
are generally not looking for women in
their 30s
they're looking for women in their 20s
women are looking for older men
generally yeah women like older men
right
so an older man
that and that is why a lot of the time
when uh men
are
are older they go for younger women and
and the women of their age like oh he
found a newer model he found a new model
all that kind of stuff right men older
are looking for younger women so women
that are older looking for men at their
age their age they're not even looking
at you they're looking at men the women
that are younger men across all ages
prefer women between 18 and 24 years old
according to okcupid data
like men men your age
you're 28 you said right right 28 year
olds you but nobody
so all right so you want an older man
yeah right so generally
and you could probably get an older man
at this point in time right but i'm
saying once you get into your 30s
a woman in her 30s he's looking for a
man on her kind of same age he's not
looking at you looking at younger he's
looking at a younger woman look he's
looking at you
you know i mean he's like looking at you
do you know what i mean and it's like
that's when we started getting oh we're
at a good man what's going on they're
just not looking at their good men out
there they're looking at you they're not
looking at you you're looking at younger
when me and martial go out they do think
we're the same age yeah which is fair
which is fair
right which is fair but that only but
i'm saying that only happens for a
certain amount of time
well by saying that only happens for a
certain amount of time and i just think
people need to get more realistic so i'm
41 right so i understand that if i'm
looking for a girl
thank you
but i'm saying i'm 41 so if i was
looking for a woman at 41
i know that the woman at 41 has probably
got a couple of children right
for a couple of guys and i've now got to
go into a situation
that maybe is not the best for me
because i'm thinking what's a 41 you're
a room with a couple of right so me
no there are but i'm saying so me as a
41 year old i'm thinking maybe i'll find
someone a little bit younger
because i know that younger women are
looking for older men
right i know that but old but younger
men are not looking for older women you
guys are looking for looks you guys just
it's about eyes we are about what we
listen you know and i think like mature
men like they know
so what about height
women women also look for looks like
like heights that's very physical teeth
the thing is i got fed good genetics
because i'm six foot two do you know
what i mean like like i didn't choose to
be six foot two but i understand the
advantages of being a six foot two guys
you know what i mean like i understand
the advantage of being six foot two but
you're saying
women are looking for heights i
understand
women looking for guys like me yeah yeah
i don't like looking for guys like me i
understand that as a man
right i i'm in high demand so i now when
the women come i could be like i'll
choose
that one you know i mean i i can do that
not most men can't yeah yeah and i
understand that advantage that i have
and so when you say like oh there's some
men that'll do it it's not it's not the
men we typically want
no it's the
there are men that will take any woman
in here in a heartbeat
but but you guys will be like but
right now but you wouldn't but no but
you wouldn't be like but we'll be like
ugh
women married in their 20s without
living together had some of the lowest
rates of divorce
sega women married in their 20s without
living together had some of the lowest
rates of divorce
so you're saying older women get more
divorced yeah
no but but it's just interesting because
when you when you were talking earlier
and you were talking about in the old
days they were like forced to be married
and they weren't happy
how how are we happier now if one in
four women are on antidepressants
i i'm not um educated enough to answer
that i just don't want to say something
that's going to make me something okay i
i don't yeah
i don't expect like people to have sex i
was just curious like why
i just think we live in such a different
society now that that's true
antidepressants are probably caused by
so many other factors that is i just
don't even really know how to compare
the two
i think social media is definitely oh
yeah 100 it affects people in different
ways i would agree um
social media is [ __ ] up
i would say with social media what is
the main thing that you see on social
media as you scroll
it's oh
[Music]
and so as as you get older and if you
don't have that and that's all you see
on social media as you get older the
people that are in your group the people
that you grew up with you're gonna see
it more because you're getting to that
age where it's like man you're getting
married you're having kids what's going
on and i'm i'm in that state like i'm
like man this person's having kids this
person's getting married and it's harder
as you get older to not see it and so i
would say that that is social media is a
huge factor of
more women having
being more depressed or being unjust
unhappy with life and just the fact that
they're like well i'm i'm doing this
with my career i'm doing this
and people have told me focus on me
focus on me but when does it come time
for me to to be able to be that person
for someone else i focus on me for so
long
when when when does that time i've never
been told i'm not saying myself but it's
like i've been told to focus on me for
so long by this person by that person
what's the next step after i focus on me
for 10 years i want to progress but no
one is saying like after you focus on
yourself up to a point there does come a
time where you will have to not have to
but where you will
need to step out of that me me me me and
be able to welcome somebody else into
your space i think that's something that
is not talked about it's very like
independent be independent yes be
independent have your own but also know
that if you have the idea of getting
into relationship you're going to have
to understand like you're not going to
be alone you're going to be with someone
and how do we
essentially change the narrative from
being it's like a gear shift after
you've been with yourself and learn how
to love yourself learn how to be
independent how do you bring somebody
else into that equation
well and i think
um that was that was really good
but i think like a lot of those
suiting is do you have a nice voice
i need a tambourine like a man
every day oh wow thank you
well i think a lot of times like
we
we're like in fear of getting hurt so
like men don't want to let women in
because they're afraid of being used for
their resources and women don't want to
let men in because they don't want to be
used for their bodies or like cheated on
or like traded for a young old model but
it doesn't get anyone anywhere
it's just
it's fear we're living in fear right now
makes everyone lonely
sorry we've got some super chats
um i'll read them out as fast listen i
want 10 of those super chats
um so we have slg saucer
25 um feminists reject the physical
sacrifice needed
we also have stefan benty
on my way out thought i'd stop and show
support martial's energy is great for
the show looking forward to see what
comes out next from her mouth
so yeah
um forum
feminist equals the idea that biology is
a social construct
nice fact
um mavericks s
uh when feminists are saying men are
trash
or down the patriarchy that is
judgmental
okay
amen
dania
seems like every generation simple adopt
i'm sorry sorry it seems like every
generation simply adopts social norms
without understanding much do y'all
think people are ill-informed
when it comes to the inter dynamics of
their sexes
um
we have the uk economist a question for
the ladies would you rather your
daughter be a virgin until marriage to a
respectable man or
sleep around to find herself
oh
i would
first i would ask her what she feels
like you know
even if she's my daughter she's a human
being she has the right to choose what
she wants
of course i would let her know in
advance everything like
you know how to be cautious and
you know
i say
sex uh
and be aware of men you know uh like
their games and that that because i've
been there so i will tell all the tips
and you know advice and all that and i
will let her decide you know
so um would which one would you rather i
understand you'd let her decide but
which one would you rather
and we'll go around
just give me a minute no worries
[Laughter]
option b
okay so i allow her to sleep around and
finally defined herself here yes most
definitely okay
yeah b
b
come back to me come back to me sure i
mean i'd say virgin
i'd say but i'd say a virgin
for me i
i would say a version um
i would also
like teach her about the
precautions that could come with
her sleeping with multiple people and in
the end
if you if she chooses she chooses but
for me i would want her to stay aversion
because i would do you know you know
what's so funny is that like societies
before the this
western society
regardless of where you went around the
world
asia africa
whatever continent had that system they
had the system of
women must stay virgins until marriage
right like they had that system it's the
it's the quote-unquote western system
that changed it like you go to the
middle east they still have it
certain parts in africa you can
literally go into that the jungles of
south america like a tribe they'll still
have that kind of you know that kind of
uh i think they are system they know
how much like the wrong guy can really
damage a girl
i think
they call i hate this term but they call
it alpha widowing in the red pill
and it's basic so it's basically like if
a girl sees the guy
as like the best that she could have did
and it doesn't work out
she's in essence ruined for the next guy
because she will always think about that
last guy right
so it doesn't matter like who she sees
and acts like she'll always
unless she finds someone that's like i
hate the word but like more alpha than
the last guy she's like that guy's
always going to be in her head
i think every woman has probably got
that guy in their head right now shut up
sarah i'm just saying
everyone's got that guy in the head
right now right no no no the guy who
hurt me it was awful but it was not the
most obvious no the guy that you
definitely go back to that the guy that
you compare other men to
oh yeah but he's amazing
it didn't hurt me does every woman have
that guy that you compare other guys to
you right now i didn't say it like no
like we when we broke up
it was like for nine months it was like
it was it was pretty chill it was pretty
cool with some friends we still talk
after like i said six years you know so
so do you have that guy in your head
right now that you compare other guys to
jess
that's a yes because you took too long
i'm thinking it may not
for me it may not be one specific
guy but there's certain things that
someone has done is like okay i like
that from that person i like that from
that person if i could like
build a man i'd be like okay i want this
i want that like when you go into a
candy store like i'm gonna fill this is
my bag with this and that so i wouldn't
say there's one particular guy that i'm
like man
i dropped everything for that person but
there's just certain things that
certain guys that have done and i'm like
i would want that in in your next year
it's hard it's how it's hard out there
um i don't think as a guy
you kind of
all right guys compare but it's not so
much like
guys compare like things sexually
do you know i mean like they compare
like women sexually and how they like
it's not like
i'm not gonna lie everybody i think
every guy has that one girl that they
know was the one that got away maybe
because
yeah maybe because they were
two they were too dog-ish they didn't do
the right thing but they look back and
they think ah that was the one
do you know i mean like i think
everything's not for you don't worry
about it
he misses you
yeah
you're the one
[Laughter]
yeah i think every guy like because guys
go through um
they go if you are like active in having
relationships and sex guys experience
different you know i mean i think people
experience different things you know i
mean and then you realize
at that time
maybe you weren't ready for that thing
do you know i mean but now you think ah
if i i'm ready now
and if yeah
you know i i've heard them they say this
in the man of sphere that men can love
multiple women at the same time one
hundred percent what but women can only
love one man at a time i've done it i've
done it and sometimes it's not the man's
100 percent i've done it i know
you don't get confused
i know i know i can love more than one
woman at the same time i know it i've
done it that's the crazy thing when it
comes to men and women
they
it's just
in them
and it's not a bad thing you can't just
do with
in them to be able to
why do you think like in certain
societies like
men can have multiple wives they can
love multiple women
i mean it's the truth like men can love
multiple women
they can i just but they can be
vice versa
you know but doesn't mean that i mean
i mean if i put that in my mindset like
you guys do in a way like arab men as
well they can marry like for example
foreign allows the men to marry the
other women no but why'd you say this
woman has to allow hang on but why'd you
say it's disgusting it is disgusting why
how can you say i love you i want to be
to spend
like the life with you and then you go
to the other woman next day you jump to
the next woman and in the third day go
to the third wife and the fourth day
goes to the fourth wife and then the the
problem is
the problem is the [ __ ] the problem what
the [ __ ] the problem is you don't
understand the mind of a man
and then one to
i'm trying to i'm trying to make you
what i'm trying to say is
men are white men are men are wired
differently from women okay we're wired
differently okay so we are able to love
multiple women at the same time you
don't get it because it's not your
wiring right it's not your it's really
not your wiring i'm able to love my
husband and i'm able to love my my child
and my father you know and you guys are
males as well right okay don't call me
it's not sexual but that's the thing you
guys are hoes you guys are the [ __ ]
host and then you shame on us we are
hosts because
if we are on the streets you know you
are the [ __ ] host no
you guys are not liar are from the
streets these noises online you like the
chris brown the song these toys these
hoes are not like okay i need to you're
sorry i'm not
it's not about the women it's about the
okay so statistically
specifically on the planet on the planet
so let me just give you some
okay so let me let's just now
statistically on the planet there are
more women than there are men
right there are more women on the planet
in the realm
on the whole globe
okay okay okay okay okay okay there are
more women on the planet than there are
men
if you paired every man to every woman
on the planet there would still be
millions of women hang on
wait just wait there would still be
millions of women
left over left over on the planet what
are we now to do with those women that
didn't happen because it's like a
natural thing that there's naturally
more women it's because men died in the
wars that's why there's that
yeah that's why and men leave less than
women like sis
come on the the question i'm asking
people
they say women live longer the question
i'm asking you i want to answer yes
i'm asking a very specific question
and i want a specific answer if we paid
every man to every woman on the planet
right now but not everyone is straight
for yeah but even if
hang on hang on
but but the thing is we take that we we
we're not talking about even with the
gay people just saying like
hypothetically no no but i'm saying even
with the gay people they only make up a
certain percentage i'm saying there will
still be
millions of women left over what are we
now to do with are those women
hang on are they now to become lesbians
is that what you're saying no i'm not
that's not the question i'm asking i'm
asking a very specific question what are
we now to do with those women but that
would never happen
right so the po
so the point it does
so you need like so the point i'm making
is
so the point so
so the point i'm making is
polygamy
right it's not an unnatural thing it's
actually a balance of the planet for a
man to have more than one woman it's
actually balancing things out women have
not learned okay that they are to share
a man sometimes not all the time but
sometimes you're gonna share a man
because that man if he has the resources
that you want any and he's displays all
the qualities that you want you are
going to share that man so how would you
feel that there would be reverse like
like i said there's not the numbers to
do the reverse oh no but they're still
like no no no no because hang on and i
can go to another guy hang on because
most because like like like pearl said
earlier okay but like pearl said earlier
on when women
have these criteria for their man they
pick
20 of the male population generally 80
of women pick in their head 20 of the
male population so if so i'm asking so
if 20 of the male population have 80 of
the women to choose from
do you think what that one man is only
going to be sleeping with that one woman
i never saw no one as a woman coming
like oh i need a man you know like uh
please i'm alone all these eighty
percent with women have men and i don't
have police and if you marry i accept
you
i never saw that no but why are you
feeling about that but this is this is
what's happening so what's happening now
is when 80 of women are sleeping with 20
of men so women can say oh i don't like
polygamy i would never do that but we
pick the same guy you're already sharing
your guys so we need to go for ugly men
average guys like i said
i said this on my podcast right average
men and average women are actually
missing each other like they're missing
each other they're missing like a whole
beat because there are average guys like
we talked about earlier on like the guys
that sit down and watch
corn hub and you know like
only fans those type of guys are looking
for like women that are just like them
right but the women that are just like
them are looking at the 20 of guys and
it's like yo
there's a load of guys here
but you're not looking at them you're
looking at those
other guys and it's like well there's
average men there's average women you
need to start
you know pairing with one another you
stop average women need to stop trying
to look for that 20 20 top 20 guy and
that's what i'm saying it would it would
even out a little bit but what happens
is that top 20 guy has all of these
women and the women start saying men are
trash men are trash that top 20 percent
guy has options
sometimes he exercises old obstetrics
i'm not saying that it's right
but sometimes he does because he's got
so many women looking for him because he
knows i said i know i'm six foot two i
know listen listen there's a load of
women looking for a six foot two guy
but even as a load of women
there's a lot of men looking for meals
you know uh you know
no
your options decrease by
50 percent by the time you're 30.
so you have 50 percent
go with the steps
no no look at sophia
it does
you're right it does depend how you look
she looks good she looks real good but
she's still 50. yeah and so what guys
allow pearl to make her point sorry
sorry pearl like like it's i'm sorry no
you're okay um
the the point is
i actually i don't even i don't even
have
when it comes to
men loving being able to love multiple
women is it the same type of love for
each woman or is there something that
like i love this about her i love that
about her it's not the same type of love
it's just different love but we know
that we actually love these women and
that's the thing it's like
um
women tend to think
like i'm not saying women tend to think
actually love is not just one thing love
is like it's a subjective kind of
construct isn't it so
um i know i've been in love with two
women at the same time and i i i know
that about myself that's that's the one
that got away
one of them did
no no no no actually matter of fact
the one that got away i was just
at her no
i was just in love with her but i'm just
saying um yeah i've been in love with
two women at the same time and i
understand that the love that i had for
both of them was different i did love
both of them though so i know that i'm
just saying from personal experience
people can believe me or not believe me
i'm just saying i know from personal
experience that i can love more than one
woman at the same time so what was
different between the two
they just had different qualities
they just they just they stirred up a
different um
feeling
within me but both of the feelings that
they started with within me i liked both
of them do you know what i mean so it's
like i understood that um and this was
like way back in my 20s and stuff do you
know what i mean but i know that that
happened and i know that i've
experienced that so
i know that when people say oh no
polygamy a guy can have four wives or i
actually the last guy that i actually
one of my clients that i worked for he
had eight wives
get eight wives
he was from swaziland
wow
yeah it's like in africa so it's like he
had like eight wives and it's like okay
cool so but then it like it brings us
back to like feminism i think is what
allowed this to be honest like like
women it's like okay now we sleep with
the same men but for no commitment
so we don't even before we at least got
their resources right but now we just
got their penis
[Music]
the penis that's it you just got their
penis that's it yeah like why
so i just i don't know what what did
feminism give me
and that's why i asked like what in 2022
in the west do i need feminism for i can
go work the same as a guy there's
nothing stopping me
um i can sleep with who i want if i get
pregnant i can go get an abortion
like what
i just i don't even know what in 2022 we
need it for
if anything
i want to return our rights
you want to do what return our rights
pearl wants to be a housewife
look it look it hear me out okay before
hear me out hear me out i'm listening
before
i got to sit at home okay i got to just
not work
i got to do nothing and just bear
children marry at 19. i don't even have
to do all the dating thing it's
exhausting right right yeah yeah now i
got a one pick my own husband my dad
used to be able to do that for me
i gotta pay attention to politics now i
gotta vote i gotta drive
are you trying to bring back like the
1920s and stuff oh is that what's going
on pearl wants to go back in time she
wants to go back in time i gotta work
like what
why do we
but the thing is
so funny most women most women
if they had the option would not want to
work
if you had a guy that could take care of
you would you work would you do you want
to work
i personally would because i just like i
mean it depends what you're doing too
but like if it's something i love and i
enjoy i'm going to want to do it i don't
want to just sit at home or yeah i want
to make my own income
i want to
just be able to have my own finance
let's say i didn't have a man
and i want like i want to be independent
and learn how to take care of myself and
obviously if someone comes in and
incorporates to that
that's great so like pearl said earlier
on if drake says okay cool i'm taking on
a date drake's a multi-multi-millionaire
and he's like you know what i love you i
love you sasha you know what i don't
want to spend wrestle i'ma propose to
you you're going to be like yeah i'm a
work
i mean
[Music]
i mean the voice went up like five
octaves
to do like what i wanted you just don't
have to do it as much i mean i feel like
it depends let's say
i have my own business and it's
something i genuinely want to do for
like the rest well not is it more of a
hobby than the more of a job that you'll
be doing i guess it's more of a hobby
that i guess like right
right okay
i'm talking about work i'm talking about
going out and getting a wage
and going like
we're working on that like most of them
will not want to work if they get a guy
that's got the resources but we will do
something yeah you don't have a hobby
you have like a side hustle or a hobby
or something you know what the worst
part is all of the household chores are
automated now if we just waited until
like the 50s and the 60s
bro we can get a roomba
they got a roomba and the roomba with
the mop and the washer and dryer like
what
that is true you got a dishwasher
you can hire a maid
like you don't even have to do anything
in that age
pearl would be thriving
feminism
you got to pay attention
i mean there's men out there too to be
able to give me
no but the thing is this is your work
though this is that this is like working
so you could do this i could i loved it
with like a rich guy like this wouldn't
infringe upon that yeah no i know i i
know what you're saying though i
actually do because i i think there's
hobbies that i really enjoy like i
really enjoy youtube i really enjoy
guitar i really enjoy like singing and
they're in sports right and i would
still want to do those if i was with a
guy but it's nice to not have to pay
bills
[Laughter]
i actually like i kind of want to just
bring back the question like is there
anything else you can think of like that
we're fighting for in 2022
well since we've talked what we talked
about a lot when you say it like that i
guess
like
no unless like
in the beginning what
um being like a feminist you want equal
rights to everything or like you want
equal rights as a woman but i think now
when you see it
feminisms transition to something else
rather than just you want women wanting
equality if you get what i'm saying
so
obviously it's changed a little bit so
now people are saying feminism is more
than just wanting equality so it gets
more of a broader topic
and it gets more
political and people like talking about
it on social media and that's when like
gender wars
are happening and everything's
escalating so
i don't know i guess
um
i don't i really don't know i don't i
don't know
you guys anything
i'm just kind of i'm ill so like my
brains just
yeah it's okay i mean like we we do like
i do this for a living so it's not i
don't expect you guys to have like stats
on hand yeah i wish i knew that i wish i
knew what the topic was before so i
could have you know i pulled up my own
risk yeah
we could do it again next week yeah
give me the topic and i'll put up my
receipts yeah
is there anything like you can
i mean
i express already myself a lot
yeah but
about loving multiple women know
that's that's your jealousy that is
jealousy yeah that's your jealousy you
need to need to work on yourself
i'm gonna love someone too yeah but you
need to work on your jealousy no it's
about equality isn't it you live another
is that we don't live in an equal
society love someone else too while he
loves me i'm going to find the men that
i love too it's about equality but like
we said earlier on
you are fine with double standards that
benefit you
you're fine with double sanders that
benefit you
yeah but that will benefit you as well
what
me being with one woman sorry i
expressed myself uh not in the right way
i'm saying
you are you are been fitting benefiting
uh of multiple women and while i'm with
a man that is being with this dick sorry
for the expression but we have to be
real
in another people's you know vagina
vaginas
and then you come back to me you're
right thank you
jealousy again
um i just think
it's not jealousy it's jealousy it's not
jealousy i don't care about like if you
are with me you are with me you are not
gonna go jump in another woman knowing
that you have
then we are cool about it because you
love two or three women at the same time
and then you come back to me in the same
day or the next day and you know and
that's okay and that's jealousy it's not
jealousy it's it's dirty it's disgusting
it's just okay how do you feel let's
reverse
how do you feel like you accept that for
yourself right so now
i'm not saying that this is my life i'm
just actually just like expressing that
yeah okay but no jealousy right okay so
how do you feel me loving another man
while i love you then
if you were my woman that wouldn't
happen i would say go to him
because we're not wired the same the
point is like i don't know it's not the
same advocating for men to choose i
don't i people know i'm not advocating
for cheating
advocates
i'm just saying but but but the thing is
like we have to accept that we're
different right and so you say oh that's
gross that's disgusting
yeah they do she in the same way
she's not even worse
you're right that's true
yes like you talk about in a natured way
biological way and you need to respect
that because that's biological you guys
have to respect as well and understand
biological as well comes to women and
that's biological
oops
oops
you know you know what's interesting
about equality i just feel like women
i'm back here sorry is is that in any
relationship there's always someone like
even in female friendships there it's
never equal there's always one leader
and one follower i disagree me and my
best friend are two equals so you think
in women groups there's always an ugly
friend no
no me and my best friend are both
stunning
don't no honestly
everyone says yeah there's always ugly
friends there isn't it doesn't even have
to be about looks it's just about like
one person makes decisions more than
others
it's i i you might be maybe i should
maybe we're just the exception you you
might be you seem to be the exception to
everything today well which is good
feels good not bad at all stop the cap i
said it stop the camera i love pictures
of me and my best friends
uh oh we're gonna have the chat to break
them
yeah if we send people to rank you and
your friends yeah if you want you can
put a picture of the friend in the chat
but everyone's always gonna have their
own opinions but what i'm saying is
that's always with the pretty friends
remember we said before like why do
women lie to each other like women lie
to each other very well you know they
lie to each other very well
like i i don't understand it but i i see
it like men
men in in a male group of and in a group
of guys guys who know the guy that's
like the shortest one maybe the one
that's like doesn't get the most girls
and all this kind of stuff guys will be
like yeah cool but the thing is he will
know that that's who he is right
women
tell you're a 10 girl you're amazing
you're it's like stop lying because the
results do not oh my god the results
aren't the same i mean
i've been in this situation where like i
know my friend is like more attractive
than me right and it's not it's not like
the end of the world like sometimes
people are just better looking than you
hey but i'll tell the girls this i'm
like oh like they're talking to you
she's like oh no they're trying to talk
to you too i'm like
stop lying
i've been on a date once this man asked
me about my friend i'm like the audacity
yeah
all right what the because she like came
by and he's like who is your oh what the
but like look at it like
yeah you look great you're fine you're a
ten yeah they like one another whereas
men don't have did we the thing is men
are quite realistic like they're just
more realistic and the thing is because
yeah but we and we don't take things
personally we kind of understand our our
level in like
the way yeah we understand in the
hierarchy thank you very much like we
understand it but women tend to think oh
all of my girls are you asking about a
friend oh she's great she's amazing
she's this it's like why the [ __ ] you
lying why why why are you lying because
you know the results don't say that
you know that the guys when you go out
are not all going at your friends do you
know the guys are all a pro you know
they're approaching you maybe but you
know they're not all approaching your
friend so why are you lying
why are you like you want to be nice
right exactly
don't attack no i'm just saying i'm not
trying to attack i'm just saying men are
just more realistic
yeah for sure so yeah when it comes to
feminism i think uh to answer your
question pearl um
yeah feminism is not needed in the
western world right now because things
are quote-unquote equal now
and women are not women don't have any
rights that men don't have um the you've
shown that the pay gap
um
is a nonsense doesn't make any sense so
yeah what is a need for feminism right
now except for
hating men
who are you jess end of the show
i i don't think it's necessary i think
like i said earlier it teaches
like the main thing is to be independent
and if women want to
have a relationship at the end of the
day
it hinders them in a way and
it doesn't
feminism doesn't talk about the facts
like you stated like at 30. 90 of your
eggs out the dough
and your percentage of just
being with someone that you
want to be with it goes down as you get
older and for someone like me i'm like
i'm almost 30 and my window is closing
and so if
i feel like if that was something that
was taught
then
more women would understand like yes i
need to be independent but there's going
to come a time where i need to start
putting myself out there putting myself
in situations to be able to
find that suitor that i want so i don't
i don't think it's necessary
[Music]
we've got bear market dating the problem
with living your best life is that by
the time you realize you need to settle
down it's already too late
we've got another super chat from nsu c
um how do feminists reconcile
an agenda to dismantle patriarchy when
women of their own agent
agency agency will select men for
dominance and hence reward patriarchy
[Music]
luke carson 20 uh
sent a sticker
that's fun
um
sb jack
not pc to say but
society
would work better if older women
civilized younger men while older men
supported younger men in their
relationships
uh
ucla
jedi knight
over 90 of presidential elections were
won by taller candidates fact
it's just evolutionary biology
interesting
sp jack once again
um i s i misspoke older women civilized
young men in relationships older
wealthier men support young women
okay
um i mean
uh
daniel
hopefully i said that right uh stuck on
petty your mind needs to move forward in
thinking
lol you can't understand being childish
and petty respectively
um we have another super chat oh we've
got more wonderful um bear market dating
again only 40 percent of men reproduce
whereas 80 percent of women do according
to dr
baumeister
dna analysis uh the uk economist in the
in the past parents would help with
matchmaking this meant average people
married each other and creating balance
in society do you think average men now
are invisible to most women
yes
nice
um
hedgehagger ladies
do you register for your national draft
if the answer is no then you need to
return to your voters registration card
it is the price of citizenship
i can't even vote in this country so
can't even answer that one last super
chat from maverick s uh women can you
have multiple husbands
sorry women can have multiple husbands
but that woman must provide resources
money and protection to all
his husbands
not me so
that's interesting not me
that's interesting
because
essentially
if if the roles were reversed and a
woman had say three husbands
are the men
all taking care of her and themselves or
is each man taking care of
everybody essentially and when she gets
pregnant whose child is it
i saw a video
i saw a video and it was like a few
years ago it was a girl and she was
dating a dude and then they talked about
bringing in someone else and they did
and they brought in someone else and
then they were interviewing and the guys
looked
miserable like i hate this and she's
pregnant with someone with one of the
dudes kids
and uh
and she was like oh yeah this is this is
our kid and the guy was like well how do
you feel that she's pregnant with his
kid they were like well we're just gonna
raise it like it's our kid that's our
kid too
and
i
i just think it's
harder
not to go back on the subject i just
think it's harder for men to
have
for multiple men to have one woman
like
yeah i'm gonna lie as a man it's
nonsense there's no way that i'm gonna
be having i have a wife and another man
in the house and we don't know whose
child it is
and i'm just gonna i'm gonna raise a
child like it's mine
like i have a child you know what i mean
so i but i do say i do say that men
between the age of like 19 to 29
shouldn't i always say people kids
should date each other
right like and if you can if one of you
can like swing it like great but i just
like i mean like if you have the option
to date a girl without kids like that's
cool yeah yeah but i just think like in
general they should like
idealistically no men want to date a
woman with children i do listen yeah oh
for sure you know what i'm saying but
i'm saying once you get to a certain age
and you're looking at women of in and
around your age bracket it's just not
it's just unrealistic yeah do you know
what i mean like
i'm
what am i going to be if i'm looking for
a woman who's like 35
what she's going to have no children
well i lucked out do you know what i
mean like 50 percent of women over 30.
50 women over 30. yeah
i'm looking in the wrong place
single and childless
but it's also another issue is like
weight but that's a whole other topic
like
because three
out of four women in the u.s are
overweight i don't know what it is here
though
i wouldn't think it would be that high
obesity in america is ridiculous man
yeah i never forget my first
my first trip to america i've never seen
people that fat
i was 18. i was like what the hell is
that i've never seen the thing is i i
was 18 times going off but i was at like
when i called them diners like a buffet
mm-hmm and i literally saw like 40
flavors of ice cream or some [ __ ] like
that i've never seen that in my life why
is there so much ice cream why is there
so much [ __ ] why is there so much food i
was just like what is going on here i
was like this is why you guys are
[ __ ] obese yeah but that was just me
at 18. yeah
um we had one more super chat um
bruce wayne to be a feminist to fight
for women's rights only being a humanist
is fighting for both how come i never
see any white males on this show
because pearl likes black guys that's
why it's not why oh my god it's actually
i invite both it's just like those are
always the people that don't comment
also if you ask them to come
right you wanna you could you can be on
the show i've had white guys on this
show they just don't see them
um okay so
um
closing thoughts let's go around and
then tell the people where they can find
you thank you guys all for coming this
was a really great show yeah i enjoyed
it um so yeah you could start
uh what regarding feminism yeah just any
closing thoughts you have and then where
they can find you um so like regarding
feminism i think it's just good that
it's given us the option because if you
want to stay at home
and get looked after by a man you can
but you can also go be independent and
[Music]
you know go get a job but um yeah you
can find me on instagram
do i would say my app
yeah well it's in the description okay
it's in the description it's the julia
one
the julia one
julia number two kxx
i think now i have more of perspective a
different perspective
so obviously i need to do a little more
of my research but
just having a better perspective and
understanding but knowing that feminism
i think is differently now than it was
then
um
and what that's about it but yeah my
speediest speedys22 follow me on
instagram followers
you're running
definitely changed my mind
in many
ways about feminism
uh but i still it is important to that
it exists and it's still
on
but in the uk and u.s i feel like
yeah i have to agree
kind of quite good but it still has to
go to in other cultures and countries so
other women can have the same right as
us
so yeah my instagram is marcia chennai
and you can find on youtube
on
the description box in the description
thank you
um venom feminism is cancer
and um it needs to be cut out
um that's my own personal opinion
uh but you can find me
on all the social medias sarah garvey
s-a-r-a-g-a-r-v-e-y
on um twitter
you can find me as the black opinion on
instagram and you can find me at sarah
garvey on youtube right here
so yeah that's my ads
um for me
my
my thoughts are i think there needs to
be more um
more
teaching of what
what is it to be feminine instead of
it just being like feminist feminist
women's individualism but
what
what are the repercussions of that i
think that is something that needs to
be taught and not just so much
individualism
um as for me you can find me on ig at
its.yeah.under
it's
dot girl underscore jess and then on
youtube you can find me at it's your
girl jess
and guys you should subscribe to her
channel we're trying to get her to a
thousand subscribers so she can get
monetized
money
because i mean if someone wants to pay
my bills
okay guys um so we have two more super
chats before we close out the show
um warrior reese woman chose to be
single mothers men don't get a choice we
are not the same maverick um a 304 is
someone who has had sex with multiple
men a man cannot be a 304
um because men don't have sex with
multiple men um and then one more
pearly you are peddling the red pill
drugs that's what we do here
we have one more super chat um
anna susie you guys need to get
lin
mia in me
sorry lin mae
talks on the show i've had i've spoken
to her twice yeah she
she's like a uk like um
she might do your show as a matter of
fact she's like a uk like social
commentator oh okay i've spoken to her
like twice
um yeah
yeah lin may um
see
i can i can call her for you and oscar
yeah
oh okay well thank you guys all for
coming this is probably one of my cute
pearl yeah i appreciate it
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
and bring that notification bell because
that way you're gonna be notified every
single time i'm live which is wednesday
thursday saturday at 9 30 unless we're
running late it might be 10 um
don't forget to subscribe